so I like doing stories on the Middle
East because I think it's an interesting
blend of seeing what people are like in
another part of the world and also how
we react to them and their culture this
week in Egypt a couple was arrested
under blasphemy laws for posting this
video yeah so there you go that's pretty
much some of the raciest stuff that I've
seen online have you ever seen anything
more racy than that you probably have a
tab open right next to YouTube right now
I'm guessing I know what you're doing so
this is interesting because again this
part of the world is very backwards in
terms of most of the things that people
in the West believe to be liberal values
women's rights gay rights general human
rights minority rights things like that
due process all the things that we hold
very important to us in the West and
they're not doing that in most of the
Middle East and Egypt's an interesting
case because for about thirty years it
was run by a dictator Hosni Mubarak and
then there was the uprising in Tahrir
Square and then he was democratically
replaced by Mohamed Morsi from the
Muslim Brotherhood and then that guy was
even worse for a year he was worse in
terms of all those rights then even
Mubarak was so then they got rid of him
and now they have Sisi who's a leader of
the military who basically is the same
thing as Mubarak and it's this country
that's really in flux it's fighting
between democracy and theocracy and
dictatorship and all this stuff and it's
really interesting to see a country in
this position now of course we backed it
either way when it was a dictatorship
for the first 30 years we were big
friends of them second most military aid
then they were a democracy even though
they weren't good to their people we
still helped them
financially and we do it again now we do
this with all kinds of country so I
don't make it about Egypt but this is
the type of thing that that part of the
world needs that they need to have some
free expression of sexuality and and
being able to see women that are
uncovered because all of those things
all of that repression whatever the
society you live in and whatever
religion you're under when you're
repressing all of this stuff right as
Bill Maher says it's fertile ground for
craziness and then that's what breeds
extremism in every religion and that's
what breeds you know terrorism and all
kinds of stuff
so we I don't know I don't know what
we're supposed to do because a lot of
times we comment when I do videos like
this a lot of times you guys will
comment that you know we should just
leave them alone don't do anything I'm
not saying we should invade them on that
but there's got to be some way we can
help some of our values because I don't
think as I think a lot of times liberals
for some reason we're afraid of our own
values we're afraid of our own freedoms
that are the better things it's just
true that equality of the sexes and you
know better treatment of minorities and
better treatment of gay people and all
that stuff that stuff is just better and
we have that in the West and I think we
have to figure out a way of showing it
to the world that doesn't necessarily
involve dropping bombs on them anyway
what do you think are you are you
freaked out over this video is that the
most controversial body lewd thing
you've ever seen what do you think my
thoughts will let us know in the
comments right now